adelante gracias
aulas chicos como están muy buenos días
es mitad del día son las 12 ya casi en
verdad me da mucho mucho gusto poder
estar aquí con todos ustedes y saber que
en su mayoría es una generación joven a
ver que levanten la mano están los
jóvenes los jóvenes
bueno por ahí también también es joven
ok pues bueno la idea es que les vamos a
platicar un poquito acerca de esto que
acaban de ver que están viendo en sus
pantallas algo bien interesante una
imagen una frase que dice muchas cosas
están de acuerdo dice misión fracaso el
arte emprender sabes que hoy en día
bueno el tema emprendedurismo está por
doquier las universidades hablan de él
este te metes a youtube y encuentras
muchos muchos temas de emprendimiento
escuelas de aprendiendo bla bla bla bla
que lo que yo quiero decirles a lo largo
de mi vida mi vida profesional no que
efectivamente ha sido relacionado con
esto les puedo comentar que he subido
muchos fracasos muchos muchos fracasos
de los cuales en verdad me enorgullezco
hace como 10 años cuando me despidieron
de las compañías globales más grandes
que uno puede trabajar aquí en méxico
con proyectos súper interesantes y
cuando me dicen nada absolutamente es
nada un día imágenes en casa no sentado
en la mañana digo bueno qué cara me va a
ser de mi vida si diez años realmente no
sabía no sabía cuál era mi propósito en
verdad
michele un momento muy difícil en mi
vida en el que fue
fue caminando poco a poco y después de
10 años hoy les puedo compartir estos 5
estos 5 consejos que yo les doy a
ustedes como jóvenes para que realmente
analicen lo piense y saben qué es lo más
importante que empiecen a tomar acción
es lo más importante que empiecen a
tomar acción que no se esperen
esos cinco consejos a lo largo de mi
vida en verdad pude definir que fue que
son esas cuestiones que te llevan al
éxito hoy después de 5 de 10 años es
encontrarme absolutamente sin empleos
sin chamba sin propósito en la vida
podemos decir que llevamos una visión
que llevamos una visión que llevamos una
estrategia y hemos ayudado a muchas
personas a salir adelante a través de lo
que hacemos en la agencia que lo que
nosotros hacemos lo que nosotros
recomendamos uno
inspírate
y así otras
eso ya empieza a oxigenar el cerebro
inspiración cómo logras de inspiración
en un mundo con tanta información esto
es lo que tienes que hacer enfocarte en
inspirarte señores y les voy a compartir
un slide hace 10 años obviamente sin
chamba no tenerla que hacer sin trabajo
deprimido en la casa tú te pones a ver
que encuentras en internet y encontré
una plática una plática que me inspiró
como ustedes no tienen idea y a
propósito del lugar donde estamos es
esta
porque las escuelas matan la creatividad
eso fue hace 10 años el señor sir ken
robinson hoy en día después de 10 años
ustedes nuclean cuales la platica temas
vista y es el top one xavi vean la frase
porque las escuelas matan la creatividad
entonces qué es lo que pasa esto me
inspiró mucho dije caramba tocarle el
chip totalmente y que lo que pasó pues
efectivamente me empecé a dedicar y a
buscar más acerca de esto y me empecé a
que otra vez a cuestionar cuestiones
'señores segundo punto hoy todo lo que
pase en este mundo lo que les digan sus
profesores sus padres etcétera
cuestionen se lo nunca antes en la vida
del ser humano había tanta información
disponible y hoy está para que ustedes
la utilicen y se cuestionen y lo bucle y
lo vea cuestiones y ahí es donde yo me
cuestioné después la creatividad porque
las matas y empecé a estudiar escuelas y
efectivamente las escuelas obviamente
llegas vienen te damos y digamos lo dice
lo tienes que repetir va sacas
calificación by es lo que te sean las
escuelas que pasa también las escuelas
aquí vienes a ser excelente ok
aquí no vienes a fracasar
se castiga el fracaso se castiga la mala
calificación
entonces ahí es donde hacen match cree
actividad que es creatividad
crear paz eso es lo que es crear de ahí
viene tus imagínense que vienen a crear
a la universidad ustedes vienen a seguir
información vienen a seguir a tomar esa
información que ya se había dado durante
siglos y ustedes vienen a llevarlos no
hay oportunidad para crear no existe
si saben entonces por eso es lo que pasa
cuando tú tienes creatividad es crear
algo nuevo a veces de la nada ok tú
sabes dónde viene
el tercer punto
entérate y ahí es donde empieza toda la
información disponible que hoy en día
ustedes tienen y ahí es donde yo me di
cuenta de algo y bien importante señor
es muy importante repasemos rápidamente
las heras económicas de la humanidad
la era agrícola ok todo el mundo se
dedicaba que realmente a pastar a los
animales realmente a llevar la comida de
un sembradío etcétera y así fue por
muchos años éramos emprendedores señores
hasta que llegó la era industrial ok la
era industrial donde en masa nos fuimos
a las universidades parques y a aprender
cómo deberíamos de comportarnos en cada
una de las áreas de la fábrica de las
líneas de producción
después a la que jolie ya la era
corporativa que actualmente le estamos
pasando miles y miles de personas
trabajando en corporativos en un
cubículo ok ya no es una línea de
producción es un cubículo esclavizados
esclavizados con un horario de trabajo
de 9 a 5
si tienes oportunidad llevas tu lonche y
tu top y ya lo hiciste pero si no no esa
es la vida o india corporativa salen de
las universidades regresan para estar
descansados
en un horario de 5 horas en un trabajo
que te promete una jubilación elegante
en eso hoy estamos
en una era señores que se llama la era
del talento hoy no mañana hoy es la era
del talento con toda la información
disponible que tenemos hoy en día
ustedes pueden ser agentes de cambio y
lo tienen que hacer ahora no después
sucediendo ustedes son la generación del
futuro la generación de la hora
hace 20 años hace 10 años todavía
podrían decirnos que nosotros los que
estudiábamos nos acabas tu título y vas
a tener un empleo genial si te va bien y
teme ir bien en la vida hoy en día no es
así señores mientras las corporaciones
están derrumbando están despidiendo
gente
a todo lo que da por la tecnología por
los robots por todo esto que ustedes ya
saben realmente hay muchas personas que
estamos regresando que están ingresando
a la universidad y no sabemos qué hacer
entonces hoy es momento de que ustedes
tomen la iniciativa
revolución a ti
la cuarta el cuarto consejo que
revolucionar te cambia tu chip no
esperes a que la educación cambie no
esperes a que la universidad cambie
ellos no van a cambiar no existe no se
va a cambiar por ahí va a evolucionar
pero no van a cambiar y ustedes no
pueden esperarse a que eso suceda
ustedes hoy tienen que tomar riendas
tienen que ser agentes independientes no
es el próximo semestre no es cuando
salga es ahora tienen que cambiar el
chip tiene que decir como yo si puedo
cambiarlo
los maestros no van a cambiar la
universidad no va a cambiar el sistema
no va a cambiar señores si ustedes van a
seguir pero ustedes tienen la
oportunidad de hacer algo para cambiar y
el tipo y más importante
reta t
que se retrate
recta que a ti mismo y no va con los
indicadores que hace cinco años dijeron
es que tengo que sacarme las
calificaciones en un recurso de la rive
acá tengo que consumir un buen trabajo
no reparte ahora
y son tres principios básicos al que yo
le llamo las tres es chao está muy de
moda está el chalet pues ha ganado que
realmente sea por tu vida no haga algo
que realmente nos apoya salir adelante
hoy señores nos esperen es la palabra no
se espere no sean irrelevantes por dios
haga algo la el reto de las tres es
imagínense en un mundo paralelo en el
equipo a partir de ahora usted lo van a
llevar a cabo distribuyan su vida
universitaria nueve semestres en
promedio seguramente por aquí ha de ver
los que están iniciando seguramente está
también aquí los que van a la mitad oa
los que vayan lo último cualquiera que
sea su caso podemos identificar lo
siguiente y mis consejos en verdad para
que no sigan perdiendo más tiempo son
los siguientes estudian del primero al
segundo al tercer semestre echarle todos
aquellos que ustedes saben al estudio si
se vale si no me gusta va a tirar la
toalla en verdad tiren la toalla no
puede ser que el séptimo octavo semestre
ni a la cara y no me gustó la cara y no
le se me complican las mates tiren la
toalla pero háganlo estratégicamente en
los primeros tres semestres ok
dedíquense estudiar si tienen que cortar
a su novia corte la
si no tienen que ir
para su novio
si tienen que quedarse los jueves y los
viernes estudiar haganlo son tres
semestres para darse cuenta que lo que
están estudiando es lo que realmente les
late meterse con todo el segundo cual es
emplea t vamos a romper paradigmas ok un
paradigma que tenemos por generaciones
lo que nos han dicho en nuestra casa
dijo esto etapa de estudio es tu única
responsabilidad es es sacar buenas
calificaciones levante la mano quien me
ha escuchado eso de sus padres
claro pero bien sí claro que sí me lo
dicen pues que creen a partir de ahora
eso ya no existe eso era hace 20 años 10
años hoy tienes que salir al mundo real
y no como una beca por dios a escribir a
trabajo soy becario de aquino trabajo
real hay muchas oportunidades que puede
ser en el mundo
ya fuera trabajé por ahora por parte de
time emprendan a ver lo que un cliente
molesto de si sabes que no quiero este
café te tardaste mucho sepan cómo
negociar eso es súper importante cuarto
quinto y sexto semestre estudié y en
plentzia en verdad el trabajo simple si
alguien me ve si alguien ya pregunta
menciones a mí si pudiera regresar el
tiempo
y por otra vez estuvieras en la
universidad que te hubiera gustado estar
fue a ser mi respuesta es trabajar
aunque sea
envolviendo en verdad
la despensa pero tener contacto con el
cliente sentir lo que escucha el cliente
eso entregarle el producto el servicio
en un mostrador me hubiese encantado
realmente
ok entonces la oportunidad cuarto quinto
semestre estudian y en plentzia
ok el tercero y más importante
emprenden
emprendan que es emprender señores por
dios es que sabes que es que todavía nos
llama en materia de emprendedores
en prenda y que emprende comercializa un
producto y servicio realmente pónganse
en internet en facebook
señores viendo esto ok váyase a un lugar
a un evento comercial y sepan lo que es
cobrar lo que es vender lo que es cuando
un cliente está insatisfecho y les
hables oye no cumpliste con mis
expectativas hagan lo comercialicen un
producto y servicio emprendan en ese
sentido o si no también es válido
emprendan por facebook emprenda por
internet empresa por las redes sociales
se puede una marca una buena idea y
lanzar al mercado es lo que yo les
quiero les quiero comentar
realmente señores
le quiero les quiero dejar al y con esto
me quiero despedir
crea tu propio caos y deja que el mundo
lo ordene por ti qué es esto hoy más que
nunca en toda la historia ustedes no lo
saben que ustedes llegan por generación
generación se vuelo yo estoy viviendo mi
vida estoy viviendo mi generación a mí
me dijeron que tengo que sacar mi título
ya haber ahí como me las arreglo eso no
es cierto
hoy en día ustedes tienen que
reinventarse porque no hay nada la
universidad nos va reinventando bueno
ellos tienen 100 años de retraso sus
padres que les digo nos van a seguir
cuidando la cultura latina ese estudio
te cuido hijo yo te cuido
hasta que me traigas ahí lo pongan
comedor no tiene que hacer eso hoy día
ustedes se tiene que revolucionar y
poner
ponerse en acción cree en su propio caos
en verdad los invito a que se cuestionen
a que cree su propio caos y realmente se
revolucionen y dejen en verdad y van a
ver como el mundo lo va a obtener por ti
no dejen que el mundo les diga que hacer
ustedes creen su propio caos y el mundo
se va a encargar de ordenarlo por
ustedes muchas gracias